the dehumanization
um that's operating broad scale is
having an awful effect on the way people
interact with each other because
as you've just said if i'm only dealing
with an avatar that avatar is either
going to give me what i want or they're
not and if they don't they're a
defective avatar they're an iphone that
doesn't work properly or an app that
needs updating and i'm very cross and
i'm very frustrated that it's not giving
me what i want sad but
that's what where
our brains have been entrained to think
about life and relationships and people
in a highly narcissistic way
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
author and youtuber richard graham and
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much for having me on i'm a huge fan
i've been for years
props to you guys it's uh it's taken a
lot of courage to do what you do much
respect from all of your fans i'm sure i
can speak on everybody's behalf we
should really appreciate what you've
done and the risks you've taken some of
them hate us mate but thank you very
much
listen it's great to have you on the
show uh you do great work as well um
there's obviously a lot of stuff we'll
get into but before we do just tell
everybody who are you what is your
journey through life how have you ended
up here what have you been doing with
yourself um that's a good question my
mum asked me that a lot what would you
do with yourself i uh probably
should start but i got a degree in
psychology and um i thought that i was
gonna
join the army and do the officer
training and then try and get into
military intelligence that was my hope
um
i was out in uh chester and i got i got
glassed in the eye and that sort of made
me wait a little bit because i had i had
some ptsd from that was it it was a it
was a homophobic attack i was
head-butted and hitting the eye with a
glass for being gay
um [ __ ] hell yeah no i still it was a
it was a half pint glass so he shattered
it and like little bits so i still have
bits in the bag under my eye and my nose
and stuff
um and
that sort of made me take a little bit
of a step back
and have a look about what i wanted to
do i drifted for a bit i started doing
little bits and pieces of counseling and
i started doing nightclub security so
for about 10 12 years on and off i was
doing nightclub security was teaching
some of the lads little bits and pieces
because i was always into martial arts
and that that sort of developed into
um a self-defense business an online
self-defense business
and
after about 10 years of doing that what
i noticed with the lads that i was
training they'd be like other martial
arts instructors some soldiers
bodyguards fighters
they had problems with their assert
themselves and a certain personal
boundaries and it was coming up again
and again
so i created a sideline thing called
spartan life coach the original business
was called street fight secrets
very imaginative
and uh it was it was for guys who
couldn't
you know they could shoot you in the
head or punch you but they couldn't say
no to their wife and kids so i thought
that was going to be the thing that i
was going to do
and that was in about 2013 and then i
started posting online about asserting
personal boundaries
narcissism psychopathy the types of
people who would predate on others
either physically or emotionally and
blew up it really really blew up and so
the last
eight years has been a focus on
childhood trauma codependency narcissism
and all of that type of thing which
brings us up to today i think in short
form and one of the things i was going
to ask you it's interesting i've done a
lot of personal development i studied
hypnotherapy i did all the nlp and all
that stuff and a lot of it i i don't
actually think
nowadays with the benefit of higher side
was that great
i'm glad i've done it though yeah but do
you think first of all that people get
into it's the same i think often with
martial arts people who get into martial
arts are quite often people who are
compensating for being bullied or
they're trying to look for a way out
it's the same with personal development
stuff quite often i think people get
into it because they're trying to
resolve their own stuff like you
mentioned getting ptsd and sort of do
you think that's that's a that's a thing
that happens there's a huge crossover
between the types of people who would
seek out neuro-linguistic programming
hypnotherapy which was me i did the same
thing
uh trained at 18 uh here in london with
richard bander actually as i was doing
the martial arts stuff so yeah it's
compensatory
almost like looking for
powers it's like an infantile response
you know you've been hurt you've been
bullied you don't know how to deal with
that so you look outside for things so
that you won't get hurt again i think so
yeah there was a huge crossover between
not everybody who does martial arts does
nlp but there's a there's a fascination
there is a mutual fascination between
the two subjects for sure
because for me it was it was less of
that it was much more about skill
acquisition i felt that i had a lot of
deficiencies in certain areas but i did
find and this is actually what worried
me about a lot of the personal
development industries you you these
people were being trained to help other
people but they weren't really in the
position to help anyone because
he's very kind
some of them are scumbags is that no no
i don't even mean that i just think they
hurt people who hadn't processed their
own [ __ ]
trying to help other people yes yeah no
it's it's it's it is it is questionable
um and there's a there's a scale i mean
you do have like full-blown predatory
types who are real scumbags right the
way through to well-intentioned people
as you say who are just hurt and they
haven't resolved their own issues
you could say the same thing for
psychotherapy and counselling yeah
the more legitimate sort of institutions
where
yeah do you know there are such a thing
as fat boxing coaches there are fat bjj
trainers you can learn from somebody
who's not living that life fully
themselves
but how much and especially when it's
about uh core wounds from childhood and
your emotional intelligence if you're
dealing with somebody who fundamentally
isn't very emotionally intelligent yeah
you're right there's only so far they
can take you and it gets dangerous so
what do you think is a is a healthy
approach because look i actually believe
personal development is very important
and you know the stuff you create and
talk about how to identify certain
things it's all what do you think is a
healthy way for people who are maybe
looking to
improve things in their life or like
what is a healthy way of dealing with
that
i think
what would save us all a lot of trouble
is um if we took the advice i think
freud took it from dostoyevsky and the
brothers karamazov which is we should
seek to be as rigorously honest with
ourselves as we can and you have that as
the starting point as soon as you start
bullshitting yourself and bullshitting
other people you should stop there's no
too many people involved in the nlp
community
think and talk about nlp like it's a
trick for tricking people getting girls
into bed getting people to buy used cars
or buy things they don't need should
never have been seen that way so
if we start with a good principle which
is be rigorously honest with yourself
it's extremely demanding it's a very
very hard thing to follow up on and
painful too extremely painful um and
that's where you see the that principle
overlaps with the jungian idea which is
probably something else we should bring
back
that we must integrate our shadow we
have to integrate the unconscious we're
not
little angels and saints virtuous beings
toddling around on earth we have
darkness inside of us and to say well
that's not me that's them that's outside
of me
um it's just an infantile defense
mechanism i mean in terms of
psychoanalytic theory what you're doing
it's it's funny it's scapegoating in
principle there's no sin in me i'm free
of sin all the sinners over there or
over there over there that is easy to do
commonplace but extremely dangerous
because if you start believing you're
free from sin you can attack people and
you know you you lose humility then so
that would help shadow integration would
help i think and we see that a lot right
the way for our culture now where people
like to portray themselves as being free
from sin on the one hand and on the
other hand they got right it's therefore
fine to destroy this person's reputation
or livelihood
in many ways i i the the whole project
that you guys have been engaged in
looking at it from from my perspective
solipsistically is like you're looking
at
shadow activated people and you're
trying to point out the shadow because
it's not fair these are justice warriors
but they're unjust yeah so you're
pointing out hey excuse me emperor's got
no clothes on here you're not so great
yourself you're shouting about
anti-racism in the most racist way
possible for example
um and that is that's 100 shadow
activation that's people who've
slipped into their unconscious and even
more frighteningly they find other
people who've slipped into their own
unconscious in the same way then you
have like a kind of um collective
shadow possession in certain groups and
they're egging each other on it's those
guys over there that are bad yes it's
them
every genocide every atrocity in history
starts with people doing that shadow
activation collective shadow possession
and then they identify a target and they
go for it so i think like
um honesty keeping ourselves honest
being able to reflect being able to
understand that we have an unconscious
that needs integrating and being able to
call each other out you know we should
if we uh if we trust each other and act
in good faith
you should be able to say hang on a
second francis that's you know that's
feedback that's where
psychoanalysis is powerful when it's at
its best psychotherapy works great
if you have that faith and if you have
that rapport and it's done in good faith
we can support each other to
integrate our own shadows i think over
time because we all have egos we'll have
narcissism nobody's free from it it's
interesting because we like i know you
recently watched the video that we put
out about all our journey here and part
of it that we never really got to talk
about simply because it didn't come up
is actually
a lot of the conversations we have off
screen is about you know how do we
improve as people how do we improve as a
team you know and frankly there have
been times when francis said to me look
you're doing this and it's not
constructive and vice versa
that to me is so important but we do
seem to live in a culture now where
we've been allowed because i think of
social media i don't know what your your
view is on that where we just project
this image of ourselves as perfection
and
you can't back down from that yeah in
public anymore you know yeah it's it's a
real shame it's like a sunk cost fallacy
isn't it you know you've been telling
the world and telling yourself you're
perfect for five six seven years
you've got your 1.2 million followers
you're going to go back and be like
sorry about this phone
i'm actually full of [ __ ]
um i'm a scumbag was the whole time
sorry about that you know it's it's hard
but in many ways we should i mean i just
released a video recently saying to my
followers like i've just gotten back
into a narcissistic abusive relationship
now i teach avoidance and recovery from
narcissistic abuse relationships if you
don't want to listen to anymore i
understand
i'm fallible i still have an unconscious
i still i still become shadow activated
uh
usually lost there's a bit of a weakness
but that's a weakness in in everybody so
once the
the intimacy button gets triggered the
lost button is triggered i'm not as
rational as i would be otherwise and you
do think you start to compromise on your
own moral boundaries
but these ideas that we're talking about
now they're not popular and i think that
social media is not the cause but it's
been an accelerant because it's
permitted us our own solipsism and it's
feathers our own
um [ __ ] back to us and it's got this
masturbatory quality to it you're inside
your own head
sort of pleasuring yourself with your
own wonderful
hyper idealized self-image and nobody's
cutting in and saying hang on no lads
you are actually a bit of a balance stop
sometimes you know you've got to stop
doing that and then
you've got
potentially millions of followers
telling you the same thing you say i'm
great and then the crowd says you're
great i'm great yes you are great
any of us we're human our egos are
fallible and we would fall prey to that
we would fall in love or in lost with
our own self-image at that point i think
that's that's what's happened it's an
accelerant it's a catalyst social media
it's such a good point it has fueled our
sense of narcissism you see it you see
it everywhere people constantly taking
selfies of themselves
when i was younger that just wasn't a
thing there just wasn't a thing
perpetually i was a boy yeah it was
always wrong nobody
it's not natural gary yes
but it it's true constantly taking
photos of yourself yeah that must
breathe an unhealthy obsession with your
physical appearance well um
now we know clinically from the research
you've got people out there who are
taking
upwards of a thousand selfies a day they
don't post them they're looking for the
perfect selfie
and it can be it can be upward of a
thousand selfies a day there's a case of
a boy they had to separate him i think
he was 15 they had to separate him from
his mobile phone
but because of the psychotic rage he
would go into they had to grade it so
they'd separate him from his mobile
phone for two minutes then three minutes
then four and when he got it back in his
hand he'd start selfieing straight away
so his he's an unusual case this isn't
normal but i think it shows you that
in terms of the mechanism of the human
mind how fallible it is my sense of self
is coming from that that's my mirror but
it's now not a mirror that's me this
isn't me right the real self is now here
we have to stop this we have to set
boundaries on that it won't affect us in
that way we're not digital natives
you're right yeah if if i saw one of my
mates as a kid you know those disposable
cameras really used to go on holiday
with if you turned on yourself you'd
slap them you're doing your tips yeah
but now yeah you can have a stick and
you can you know that's totally and
people stop for you or they walk around
you yeah it's
it it's
interesting to me how quickly that's
become normalized this hyper
normalization effect
because we're not that old and inside of
a decade and a half this thing that you
wouldn't dream of doing even if you
wanted to do it you wouldn't physically
do it everybody does it and potentially
thousands of times a day and to a young
mind uh
pre-adolescent 12 13 14 they're so
susceptible to narcissism
becoming highly narcissistic they want
to be seen they're trying to climb the
social dominance hierarchy they want to
know where they stand on it and they
think this device is telling them where
they stand it's it's too much for them
it's like
crack or something for the ego isn't
that the etymology of the word not
narcissism it's from
i don't know how you say his name in
english i know not sisters narcissus who
would stare himself in the mirror
endlessly how would you say i'm russian
uh narcissus nazis not nazis yeah yeah
it's exactly that and that
is also the root of narcotics
so these things it's self-obsession but
it's also a drug that numbs and it
creates sleep so people who are in their
phones are in a numbed sleepy drugged
out state of staring into their own
reflection
depends on the myth you go for but one
of them was that he stared at his own
reflection until eventually he starved
to death i find that the most
interesting one because we are starving
to death
what are we starving for
attention you think but you're getting
all the attention you could possibly
want but this is junk attention i think
it's connection that we're starving for
we're starving for connection i think
that's what it is and recognition and
and all of those things 100 percent yeah
it's it's it's a facet so far no i was
just going to say the thing that i find
most depressing is i remember once i sat
down with my girlfriend to eat dinner
and there was this beautiful young
couple next to us in their mid-20s they
looked successful and all they did was
they were just
opposite each other on their phone and
i'm thinking you're in your mid-20s
you're in love you're young this is the
peak yeah this is it and it's just and
that's that's all there is
well we we accidentally well i saw you
in a beef here you didn't see me i was
peeping at you from the restaurant was
you on his phone
running down the street singing happily
was um
the the number of times i saw that and
it was almost it was almost like you
could correlate between the
attractiveness of the couple so you see
a really good looking couple you know
mid to late 20s um exceptionally you
know these are specimens well done them
gen they've won the genetic lottery and
they're sat opposite each other and
they're not looking at each other their
heads are down which is such a weirdly
depressing and submissive posture anyway
you know you sat opposite a beautiful
woman or a beautiful man beautiful
environment it's a bether in the
summertime a great restaurant yeah
yeah you know maybe they're sending each
other memes or maybe they are
communicating through the phone
but really you can't put it down for
like an hour and a half and just talk to
your partner for a little bit
that's a real shame and they'll walk
away from that with body dysmorphia
issues anxiety depression
massive amounts of status anxiety um
it's it's really doing a tremendous
amount of psychological damage and by
the way just
very much in the spirit of shadow
recognition at least maybe not
integration but certainly recognition
like we're the same
right i would argue
other than
every now and again when i have a really
like in-depth conversation with with my
wife or my mom or my dad
it's very rare this this what we do for
work is probably one of the rare times
that even i who i'm conscious at least
of this get to sit down with another
human being
and have a conversation that's
uninterrupted by checking my emails or
whatever like that's one of the reasons
i love doing the show is we get to sit
down with interesting people and
actually it's just it's just that
there's nothing else there's nothing
else there and that is i think such an
increasingly rare thing for people to
experience
i i wonder where
you know what uh
let's just go back a sec because we've
been talking about narcissism quite a
lot we haven't really defined it okay
and i think it might be a good thing to
do okay so if if we're talking
the
what i would usually talk about is
distinct from narcissism it's
narcissistic personality disorder so
somebody who's gone through a deeply
traumatic childhood that's been a
combination of two polarities one would
be abuse and the other is a kind of
adulation of the child so the child
would have been
told that they were
can i swear yeah of course you can
you're a useless piece of [ __ ] you're
dreadful they would have been um
instrumentalized objectified sexual
physical abuse
but either the same person in their
schizophrenic state would then tell them
perhaps they feel guilty after the abuse
you're wonderful you're an angel so
they're living in this kind of split
you're a terrible piece of [ __ ] but
you're wonderful and you're an angel
the parent needs to offer them adulation
not love applause
as a member of an as an audience member
not direct love so the love has to come
through audience so you're an amazing
piano player and i love you for that
because i get narcissistic supply
vicariously you're great at physics or
you're very pretty kid or you're a model
or a little actor or whatever it is
whatever the child is then you will
experience love now you have a choice
you can either wire to the message
you're a bad object in psychoanalytic
terms it means you're a piece of [ __ ]
you're useless and you'll become
probably a drug addict and suicidal you
probably won't get past the age of 40 or
you can wire to the idea that you're an
angel
and you think well that's not so bad
yeah except you're not an angel you're a
person so it's it's
you you engage in the sex split where
you say okay i have to get more
adulation i have to get more worship so
the narcissistic personality disorder
seeks narcissistic supply that's all
they're interested in give me more
applause give me more adulation never
they never want they can't deal with
horizontal love it's unacceptable they
hate that it makes them creeped out they
like it vertical you look up to me and
tell me i'm godlike wonderful
that's a problem in and of itself as i'm
sure anybody can realize but where i
typically am talking to people about it
is they've gotten into a relationship
with somebody like that and they didn't
realize so they keep trying to offer
horizontal love i love you as another
human being and they go oh yeah that's
nice but inside they're thinking [ __ ]
you i'm not a human being i'm a god i'm
an angel i'm something better than
everybody else so there's a fight then
you're trying to love them like this and
they're constantly trying to do this and
they don't they will not accept anything
else
narcissistic personality disorder is
rigid
it's rigid so even
you can try threatening them you can try
bribing them you can try whatever you
want but they learnt this in
an infantile state and so the prognosis
for recovery isn't great because it's
their only way of interacting with the
world so that's typically what i talk
about is npd
latent narcissism we all have it we
should we should have it it's healthy
you should be concerned with yourself
you should want
yourself to do well each other to do
well you can have collective narcissism
you should want trigonometry to do well
that's narcissism uh you post uh you go
and look you see what your likes are
your followers are you check your that's
healthy narcissism you want to do well
that's a natural instinct to progress we
never want to lose that
the darkness is with the narcissistic
personality disorders it's become
entitled and exploitative and then it
doesn't care that's why it's one of the
features is a lack of empathy because
you're not a person you're just a source
of supply i'm a vampire you're food
but they will trick you they will tell
you whatever you want to hear to get you
into that relationship and then they'll
show you through actions not words that
they don't really see you as a person
they see you as food so that's that's
typically what i talk about with
narcissism
what you were saying rings so many bells
because when i was in and we were both
in the stand-up comedy industry
i remember just one day and every once
in a while like a comedian would be
outed for
normally a male comedian for awful
outrageous behavior that is just
vile on every level and you're like why
are there so many wrongans in this
industry
and then what you've just said i'm like
ah because it's stuffed with narcissists
it's it so stand-up comedy is something
when i started doing door work i started
on a comedy club and um i just come from
working for the crown prosecution
service so my head was full of
psychology but i'm doing door work so
i'm watching the the comedians go up on
stage and watching what they do
it's narcissism in action so in terms of
a ptsd trauma response
you have fight flight phone and freeze
so a narcissist is stuck between fight
which is they bully people to get what
they want and phoning which is you give
people what they want to get what you
want
stand-up comedy is a balance of fight
and phone so you're you you're actually
bullying laughs out of the crowd but
you're giving them what they want and
the best stand-up comics i don't know
like you for me it would be like a louis
ck or richard pryor at that level that's
high level narcissism
when they're really good narcissists can
be hilariously funny because they're
tuned into all your pressure points like
oh he liked that he thought that was
funny you know where you get a comedian
they're almost like a good boxer they
hit you with they hit the crowd with one
joke and then they know i'll go here
i'll go okay liver shot uppercut and the
the crowd is just like okay stop you
know tears rolling that's that's a
really high-level narcissist i'm not
saying stand-up comics
but there is
you need to understand that world to
operate in it for sure for sure
hey constantine do you like christmas no
in ussr we cancelled christmas and we
had lenion fest instead hosa we
celebrated glorious leader and rewrote
story of jesus to make it better really
yes in our story three wise men were
killed and gifts meant for jesus
redistributed to glorious workers of the
soviet union jesus was put in gulag for
having wrong opinion as we call it in
russia happy ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
akanvi she is almost as good philosopher
as vladimir lenin
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are x
i imagine
broadly speaking not just stand up but
other performing arts 100
that's why you get more i imagine
statistically speaking probably a higher
percentage of
to use the technical tom romans in in
those industries right because these are
people who are operating on that
martial arts is one martial arts
instructors huge amounts of narcissism
in martial arts a really
disproportionate representation
that's really well i imagine that's
because first it's visually you're going
to be you look good and also you have
power to that's what it is it's totally
and whatever does the job it does the
job perfectly but there's a difference
between male narcissism and female
narcissism aren't they and they manifest
differently they do manifest differently
um i just found out recently uh from a
guy i worked with called sam vaknin the
the clinical statistics now indicate
that as many female narcissists as males
for the first time ever
it manifests differently only because of
power so whatever you can do you will do
so if my power is i'm bigger than you i
can pick up a rock and hit you with it
i'll do that if my power was i'm sexy so
i can seduce people and bend their will
that way it's almost incidental um but
yes it does it does the behaviors
manifest differently but the core the
clockwork the mechanics is is the same
and how do you know you mentioned
relationships which i imagine is where
this is really like a big issue because
in normal life you can distance yourself
from people like that you can choose a
different job whatever once you're in a
relationship particularly when you
didn't know what you were getting into
necessarily yeah how does how do you
know
that you are dealing with someone who's
full-blown npd
well you know you can put a youtube
video out saying how to know if you're
dealing with somebody who's mpd and
you're guaranteed to get like half a
million views in a year because
everybody's asking that question right
how do we know
um because if you're in love with
somebody and you start to realize
there's something up and you think it
could be narcissism
it's pretty bleak and so you hope that
they're just traumatized you hope they
just have ptsd and they're having bad
days because if it's npd
it there's there's really no hope
what i would say i would be looking for
patterns of exploitativeness and
entitlement that play out across context
and across time
even when you've told them to stop
so if it seems as though they'll just
say yes yes yes i'll stop i'll go to
therapy i'll do this i'll do that and do
the other and they're not stopping and
they keep going and you've told them it
hurts and they're still doing it it's
not great because even if they don't
have mpd they are in our shell
which is which is just as good a reason
to split up with somebody as anything
else you don't need the clinical
diagnosis
um these are these are boundaries aren't
they i would say like once you've told
somebody three or four times like that
thing that you're doing it really hurts
me you tell me that you love me but
you're still doing it
three four would you give them a fifth
chance maybe you would unless they've
just been through some major trauma in
their lives that justifies it i would
say that's you
you're either looking at somebody who's
mpd or their idea of what it is to act
within a relationship that's loving and
intimate is so hot because somebody can
just act narcissistically and it can be
context specific many people in this
culture have very narcissistic defense
mechanisms around love and dating
um how do you mean
well we're in a tricky place as far as
the genders go right now and it's a bit
of a battleground out there um i know
you're both in happy relationships but
presumably before that you were dating i
never was you you were not first one bam
job done really yeah
yeah 18 years old done
good for you you saved yourself a lot of
trouble i imagine so yeah it's it's it's
brutal it's it's really brutal and it's
um
it's gotten noticeably worse uh year on
year of the last 20 years but
particularly in the last five years it's
become very savage battleground
as the genders
as the sexes split apart and polarize
the view of each other has gotten darker
and darker talked about shadow
integration before and shadow possession
as we become more shadow possessed we
engage in something called projective
identification so you just start seeing
that the person is awful even if they're
not you have two people who are
ruined spoiled by consumer capitalism
trying to consume each other
narcissistically while using protective
identification see the worst elements
that they have on to the other it's a
nightmare
put some meat on that skeleton what do
you mean when you say it's a
battleground and and all of that like
what are you talking about are you
talking about men and women starting to
be so more antagonistic or
yes men and women being more
antagonistic but to be fair um
i have heard that in the in the gay
scene it's the same thing so as far as
love and intimacy goes
we've sort of
lost a grip on what it is to be in a
relationship
and the battleground is
i'm going to try and take as much so we
have a room full of people 100 people
and they're all trying to date each
other but everybody's running a program
that says i'm going to take as much from
you as i possibly can and i know you're
going to hurt me because everybody
behind me has hurt me i'm just waiting
for when
so people are coming in armoured and
they're coming in with weapons drawn
assuming it's going to be awful that's
where the projective identification
comes in
every single guy i've ever been with has
treated me like [ __ ] you're a guy all
the data i have indicates you're going
to treat me like [ __ ]
so the the hostility levels start quite
high it's defensive
those defenses are narcissistic
typically so it's it gets um
it just gets nasty really really quickly
so it's quite hostile so if you meet
somebody randomly um like say i meet a
girl and i meet her randomly and there's
no intent there
and we're just working together or
something it'll be fine but as soon as
it's in a dating context or she gets a
sense that there could be the potential
for a relationship then the defenses go
up and it gets hostile and it gets
aggressive quickly so the way people are
treating each other now is
is with contempt quite honestly
and does that factor in as well the the
social media element like we see people
as avatars we don't see them as human
beings anymore 100 100 the the
dehumanization
um that's operating broad scale is
having an awful effect on the way people
interact with each other because
as you've just said if i'm only dealing
with an avatar that avatar is either
going to give me what i want or they're
not and if they don't they're a
defective avatar they're an iphone that
doesn't work properly or an app that
needs updating and i'm very cross and
i'm very frustrated that it's not giving
me what i want sad but
that's what where
our brains have been entrained to think
about life and relationships and people
in a highly narcissistic way
and we we're talking about a lack of
empathy at what point does this veer
into sociopathic territory
um we're there i mean
yeah i mean
we're already there so
if we wanted to say uh psychopathy or
the way the dsm defines it as
anti-social personality disorder when
i'm saying narcissism really we're
talking about narcissistic psychopathy
um it's goal orientated it's it's uh it
has these megalomania
megalomaniacal qualities to it there can
be only one there are winners and losers
in this game and i'm going to be the
winner um so yeah there is already
psychopathic elements to this kind of
narcissism that we're way beyond
uh vanity and greed now we're into
something that's much more um it's it's
got some real aggression behind it it's
got some real toxicity behind it and
where is it coming from richard
well why is it changed is what i'm
getting now why has it got worse we let
go of god
mistake um we should have listened to
dostoyevsky and nietzsche back in the
1880s they both wrote very very similar
things about it which is we're losing
god and if we lose
without wanting to lose your audience
when i say god lose our audience by all
means [ __ ] them
i'm a narcissist right not like that
[Laughter]
when i when i say god uh in this context
i i'm an atheist i can't i can't access
that i can't naively believe in god but
when we had when we had god there was
somebody or something that was at the
top of everything and when we removed
that dostoevsky and nietzsche said this
is a bit dangerous because if we don't
have that we will put ourselves there
and if we do that we kind of have to
worship ourselves
and then that's the famous when you look
into the abyss the abyss also looks back
into you
the god is dead um what
what festivals will we have to create to
justify our own sin these are the
festivals these are the celebrations
instagram facebook these are the
festivals and celebrations that we have
to tell ourselves we're amazing we're
awesome we can do whatever we want
because mummy and daddy god goddess are
not around anymore but it's guilt laden
it's it's extremely guilty and without
that reverence for something higher than
it sounds silly even saying the word
reverence it's so out of date if we
don't have reverence for something
higher there's only us
what does that create self-loathing this
is a dostoevsky point as well but if i
hate me i have to hate you because
you're also me i am piece of [ __ ] you
must be piece of [ __ ]
so that's very offensive
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm just kidding thankfully russians
seem not to care one job whenever
so
once you've got to that point and
there's just mutual contempt
then there is only narcissism left we
only have and that's wretched i so i
don't even have i don't even have you i
have me
we're not evolved for that we are a
religious species we always have been
i'm not saying like bring back a
particular religion because we can't do
that toothpaste is already out the tube
but we have to have something we have to
have some kind of a philosophy or a
psychology that permits us to say
i'm i didn't create life i didn't create
myself i didn't create you i didn't
create that which is good there is
something beyond me and at least then i
can have a tiny song of humility and not
be as arrogant and as entitled as i
otherwise would be and it gives you a
measure of peace as well like it's
interesting you're talking about all
this stuff it's like none of the three
francis myself are until none of us are
believers but we've started saying grace
before every meal right
just because it's a moment of
whatever i don't i don't know i don't
have the language that's right maybe
reverence is the right word and it's a
i know what you mean when when you
when you are
when you are at the top of that pantheon
that's not a healthy place and there's
there's something
i think we're desperately unhappy there
we know we don't belong there and
there's something you'd sort of think
well we won then we won we finally got
there and in so many ways human beings
are the victim of their own success
because another element of this aside
from losing god is consumer capitalism
this particular brand of capitalism not
an anti-capitalist but the things that
we allow companies to do in the name of
generating profit
are obscene you know it's it's
outrageous what we like people look at
you know these tech giants what they're
doing to the minds of children it's an
obscenity
that also is a problem because you're so
hyper stimulated and so constantly
messaged to a marketer too that you're
less than you're deficient you need
these trainers you need this drug in
order to live
and we are consumers then so we are
godless and we're consumers
that's wretched that's not what we're
evolved to be we're not evolved to
to be this thing so
i always think it's funny for like
hundreds of thousands of years we would
have been outside freezing
you know being chased by saber-toothed
tigers dreaming one day of the cities of
lights where there'll be food everywhere
and warmth and shelter everywhere we get
here and we're like oh this is [ __ ]
i'm sad
it always reminds me the story of george
bess the footballer i don't know if
you're into football but when he was 23
years old he he won the european cup he
was
the man of the match he was you know he
was at the peak of his fame young
handsome guy
and he said that after winning the match
and winning the cup which was the
highest accoladed footballer could
achieve he went back into the showers
and when he was in the showers he said i
never felt more empty and that's when i
knew it was over yeah these things that
we worship whether it's fame a million
you know being a youtuber stand-up
comedian eventually when the applause
dies down
you just left with yourself yeah yeah
didn't realize you felt that way
i'm actually quite enjoying it to be
honest we will have a hog after this
no i i hear you 100 and i've i've found
myself saying to people more and more
if you can't sit in a room on your own
what are you a billionaire or you're
famous or whatever you're wretched
that's wretched you can't just sit in
peace on your own and just and just
think or just read a book or
and how many people can now
everybody's so agitated and desperate
and the locus of control for everything
and the locus of self-perception is so
externalized that's what marketing does
that's what propaganda does that's what
ideology does it takes you away from
your authentic self
into a false self where you try to live
and function as an avatar
and it's uh it's it's of course it's
misery inducing it's it's anti-life
we're living in an i believe an
anti-life
ideology at the moment so
what can you do as an individual in that
situation
despair
really disbelief he's been reading a lot
of dostoy
too much russian literature will will
rot your brain this will tell you the
very sad truth about life
and you will never be happy again drink
vodka listen to sad russian folk music
and be done um
it was it was kierkegaard uh with with
despair which was and i only learned
this recently it's healthy to despair
because we stay stuck in an ideological
loop if we refuse to despair so if you
say no it's okay it's okay we're winning
the game
instagram is cool and i don't know tik
tok is great let's learn a tick tock
dance and post and get a million views
you're still stuck in the ideological
loop and kekergaard was right you should
despair if it sucks you should say it
sucks but that's kind of a social taboo
for us like if something is really awful
and you want to say this is really awful
it's a really fast way to become a
pariah it's a really fast way to get
even like criticism you guys lived at
you were like excuse me can we just
politely say that some of this doesn't
make much sense
big pushback for that big punishment for
that it's not
certainly in the beginning it's not a
rewarding experience until you find the
others and realize the support there
it's a lonely place to be in but despair
is key if we don't despair we can't
grieve
despair is essential to having an honest
authentic interaction with reality some
parts of life suck we know this the
vedic scriptures were teaching us this 6
000 years ago all of life is suffering
the gnostics the same thing this world
is not perfect it's not supposed to be
so the horror i think that we live in
now
is zizek has pointed out um is it's it's
called the fetishist split so we know
that it sucks and yet we have to pretend
that it does not and we have to stick a
smiling face on it that's torture you
should be able to say no this isn't very
good i don't like this this is not what
i signed up for and i'd like it to stop
but we've sort of been coerced into a
position where we feel like we can do
everything else but not that so despair
i know what you mean about that sorry
just this quick comment is because
i guess it's that thing of like the
first step to solving the problems
admitting you have one and if you admit
you have a problem it's quite right to
to be
at least dis dis whatever by that right
discontented yeah yeah yeah that makes
sense no
and i was going to talk to you about not
only do we feel despair not only are we
forced to put on this fake smile and
project this happy life but because of
social media instagram that's what
everybody does so to use a terminology
of the time we're all being gaslit yeah
yeah into thinking that everybody's
having this great life apart from us and
that zizek would say that is ideology at
its purest so where
we're feeding we're being force-fed the
ideology and then we force feed it back
to each other because we're not just
being told what to desire our ability to
desire is being coerced so it's not just
what to desire it's the way in which you
desire it needs to be ideologically pure
as well so yeah we're all playing the
same stupid game for who
and it's it's this double bind it's been
fed back into it says plug backed into
itself we're all doing it for somebody
else but we all know perfectly well it
isn't true
uh it's nightmarish and the way out is
yeah you want to say it's you've got it
somebody's got to go hang on
um this this sucks this is wrong let's
just
yeah i need to despair and really
despair despair is grief you go wow what
have we lost
[ __ ] hell we lost god we lost
community we lost each other look at our
children look at the state the world is
in this is horrifying oh cry weep roll
on the floor piss yourself if you like i
won't judge you um but then
the morning after you say okay now what
now now i've accepted it's wrong now
what that's where we need to get to and
so i'm an accelerationist in that regard
but we're also incentivized not to do
that we're incentivized to
carry on because the more can we carry
on the more followers you have the more
followers you have the more successful
you are and the more successful you are
in this world the more income you can
generate blah blah blah blah blah and is
this not capitalism so there's the
capitalism of of acquiring likes acquire
it's more i keep these bananas and what
what are they they're [ __ ] little
digital thumbs but our brains are so
easily tricked we think that that's a
real thing and so it's the acquisition
of more
keeps you in the game to actually step
out of the game is a huge social taboo
and it doesn't even need to be punished
or criminalized our brains will reject
it because you'll be like well everybody
else is doing this every other monkey in
my troop is doing it why am i going to
leave the tribe that's extremely
dangerous
you're genetic i believe
it's not proven i personally believe
your genetics will fight you if you try
and leave the tribe because it's death
evolutionarily it's always been death
it's difficult so if you rebel and like
you were given your your story the other
day and these emotional highs and lows
and you've got to go off in a room and
cry
is i think that's your dna saying stop
it's safe over there don't [ __ ] do
this
um it's a hell of a fight it's a hell of
a fight it is but i also think there's
also a heroic
thing in human beings
and part it is narcissism it's
narcissistic to think you're the person
who's going to go and change the world
but i do think there's a heroic instinct
in us as well which says
i know what's going on here yeah and
just because all these other [ __ ]
monkeys want to go along with it yeah
well i'm not one of you yeah i see
what's happening and i'm going to step
out and i'm going to say so and i'll
take the punishment yes i'll take the
punishment because i know what the truth
is here and the truth is this isn't
working yeah you can't have people
running around hashtag be kind while
they mob people into suicide yeah right
that doesn't work yeah so i i think
there's also that side of it as well
which is
people it's a small minority of people
in society but they're the ones that
have always made history you know what i
mean 100 i i think the way you worded
the question before was like where have
we gone wrong and what we could do about
it and we said you got to bring back god
or at least some kind of reverence you
have to despair which means you have to
be able to tell the truth about what's
going on and then maybe you could have a
third thing there which is courage
and courage means not the big flex of
saying it and getting the applause for
it but the willingness to get hurt the
willingness to get [ __ ] up that's
courage if you know you're not gonna get
hurt that's that's not courage if you
know you're going to lose your job if
you know you're going to be kicked out
of the
the comedy community that you're in
i don't know like for people who've not
done this they don't know how that fit
maybe they don't know how that feels
it's a it's an awful feeling i have
friends of yours people you've known for
years people you work with shun you
because you're telling the truth as you
see it it's it's that's that's despair
so you've already been through that one
we have you know there's a great scene
have you seen hunger it's a film about
bobby sands oh yes i have yeah yeah do
you remember there's this beautiful
scene in the middle of the movie where
the priest comes into the prison and
they're sitting and he and
bobby sands tell the story of how when
he was a kid they went on a field trip
and there was this deer that
had fallen in the river and it was
drowning and and he went over and he
knew what to do which is to finish it
off as it happened right
um and he says i knew what i had to do
and i was willing to take the punishment
right
and i remember that scene always because
when we started trigonometry
i just felt the
the the catastrophe of where we're going
as a culture
is worth risking
the little that we had at the time yeah
to actually stand up against it and say
something
and the reassuring thing for me is
you know
that there's people out there who who
are interested in hearing that there's
people out there who want to hear those
conversations and do something about it
you know 100 percent that scene that
you're talking about this isn't that
like a one-shot scene that goes on for
like 15 minutes yeah it's incredible
really good it's amazing
so you said the catastrophe um
i know that you're interviewing me can i
just ask you guys though how bad do you
think the catastrophe could be
how do how bad do you think a
prospective catastrophe could be in the
scenario we're in well actually i've got
a book you know um i but i have i'm i
have written the book which is coming
out middle of next year which is called
an immigrants love letter to the west
right and my thesis is the the process
we are experiencing is
essentially
the destruction of western enlightenment
values
and you know the existential stuff that
we talked about earlier that's that's
separate and probably even more
important but
i just know the way the world actually
works right and
people in the west can have this airy
fairy nonsense about how equality and
diversity that's not how the rest of the
world works the rest of the world works
on very simple basis if i'm stronger
than you then i'm going to take over you
right that's how it works so the moment
the west undermines itself there are
plenty of people waiting
to fill that void that power void and
china maybe russia they'll come in and
if you think racism is bad now
i'll show you what it means
what it means that's my view
what about you francis uh
from my background as being a teacher
the thing that i despair about the most
is what we're doing to our children
what we're doing to our kids you see
with transgender ideology the fact that
we give puberty blockers to
eight-year-old six-year-olds and somehow
we think that this is progressive and
kind is an abomination it's child abuse
and and the
the reason that we're not allowed to
have sex with children is because
children can't consent it's that it's
that simple and they can't consent to
take puberty blockers because they have
no concept of consequences that is a
psychological fact
the fact that we hand them
social media smartphones from the age of
10 and 11 is abuse as well because you
were just essentially
molding their brains in the most
unhealthy way possible you're showing
the most unhealthy images possible what
instagram does to young girls and to
young women i don't think i think it's
the tip of the iceberg we're gonna see
an absolute slew of girls who have go
with a variety of body dysmorphia
anorexia etc etc the fact that instagram
are trying to create an instagram for
kids have you heard about this no i
haven't they're trying to create a
specific instagram for kids
it's just vile and we're going to reap
the rewards and i find it that i find it
sad because it's not their fault and
we're going to have a generation that is
stunted as a result 100
yeah what do you think
gulags and genocide we're on the road to
it and i'd people laugh they're not not
here i'm like what do you think we're
special do you think historically we're
[ __ ] unique
um i know you've had douglas murray on a
few times but i remember he always said
when people are saying oh this is this
is a racist country it's like well try
going to another one we can show you
re i lived in malaysia if you want it i
mean it's not a terrible place but if
you want to see
institutionalized racism if you're not a
muslim malay you're in a different tax
band and there are different
universities you oh absolutely different
universities you go to different
employment laws apply to you and you
cannot convert to beca it's called boomi
putra you can't convert to it it's
ethnic it's in your blood it's and you
are in a different tax band so it
doesn't matter how many chinese and
indians are working to help boost their
economy which they are the majority
earners there doesn't matter they're in
a separate
that's racist
like what we're talking about in this
country
is
i mean specifically that's institutional
racism that is in it's enshrined in law
if it's not enshrined in law
where it's going to be difficult for us
to prove that so to the douglas murray
point as i he always says compared to
where
or compared to who how are you grading
us how are you grading our civilization
but i think on the path we're on is
gulags and genocide why do you say that
people will look we didn't laugh because
it's not funny anymore australia
segregating vaccinated people from
unvaccinated people something we would
never believe would have happened to you
i mean to be fair though those boys do
have a history for it
yeah it's austria and bavaria
we don't want your freedom
but
it's not funny anymore really because
this is this is why the shadow point
that you made right at the beginning is
so important
it's only people who truly understand
their own capacity for evil yeah and
their own capacity for social conformity
and their own capacity most importantly
for being
in in love with their own virtuousness
because that's what the nazis thought
that's what the communists and the
soviets saw they thought they were
fixing society and of course it's worth
putting a few a few you know
non-believers in a camp of course it is
because we're creating the future
brilliant society in which man will be
perfected
and it's only when you know our
listeners and you know jordan peterson
obviously has talked about this a lot
it's only when you know that you are
capable of putting people in a camp that
you might not
you know but why do you say that is your
fear why do you say that's where
potentially going uh i'm geographically
and historically literate and i'm not a
[ __ ]
when i'm looking around and i and i look
at like
the i know that um you're moving away
from talking about the woke movement a
little bit which which i understand um i
was woke i was a radical leftist when i
was a student i had the purple hair and
the eyebrow piercing and all that
studied feminism as well as the
psychology and i understand that i
understand where where these people are
coming from but as it goes through its
different iterations it's like a
photocopy of a photocopy of a photocopy
and i was about well let's not bully
people let's keep people included let's
be inclusive so my thing was like let's
be reasonable and not
excessively uh tyrannical and
let's not have a policy of the devil
take the hindmost because i've been the
hindmost and i didn't like the devil
taking me let's try and support people
fine
then it goes through these different
iterations like a virus that's mutating
over time
to something that is utterly moronic i
mean
moronic you would have to be a [ __ ]
idiot to believe that this was useful
and we're talking psychological
illiteracy emotional illiteracy
geographical literary illiteracy and
historical literacy that the soviets and
the nazis that we're not talking about
400 years ago there's people still alive
my grandmother
she lived on
half her family were
purged in the soviet thing and then the
other half of family were taken as
slaves to germany during the war she's
alive you can go talk to her perfectly
accomplishment and you've got relatives
from venezue
so
we can't just go oh we have 400 years to
go the spanish inquisition if we've no
no no i'm sorry we're the same people
we just have smartphones now we're not
better
and we and you could say well we've
learnt our lessons have we no no we
[ __ ] haven't i'd love to see the
evidence that we've learned our lessons
because we seem to be doing some eerily
similar things again aren't we going
back now to neo-segregation we we only
just gave it up 40 years ago and we're
doing it again why because it worked so
well the last [ __ ] few times we did
it so
that that's why i i just look at what i
try to say is how does it begin
obviously everything escalates once you
sort of open the the floodgates a little
bit then another one then another one
then another one yeah gulags and
genocide we are guagging people we've
digitally gulagged people how far away
is that from actually gulagging them so
now physical goo lagging
uh
as you just said it's going to take
place in austria and the czech republic
which i was living in up until uh six
months ago that's doing it for monday as
well they're following in austria's
footsteps as they usually really yes
from monday the sudan land will be visas
i'm telling you
the germans doing it as well uh yeah
they're talking about it are they really
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
do you know i took part in in um in a
debate tv debate and part of it was on
vaccine passports
and i was shocked by the other two
people by two people on the debate who
seemed very reasonable very nice
and the way they talked about
unvaccinated people just the the bile
the contempt
just the way they dismissed them
and i was shocked by this and i went to
talk to my girlfriend who's american and
i went i was just shocked by it and she
was like well why is why are you shocked
by it in america that's how everyone
speaks yeah and i was like
which one yeah that's exactly how
everyone speaks well not everyone but a
large portion of the population in
america so there's something here
to do with personality disorders and
narcissism
if somebody's heavily emotionally
dysregulated especially if they're
borderline personality disorder they
lose the ability to assess threat
properly right if this was smallpox and
it had a 30 mortality rate i would look
at on vaccinated people that way i'd be
like you [ __ ] murder you don't care
it isn't smallpox or the bubonic plague
or polio which is or yeah exactly so
i think when i look at their i'm
unvaccinated when i look at the
attitudes i'm like if i believe the
threat was as high as they do then i
would understand it but this is a threat
misassessment yes people with borderline
personality disorder who are very
emotionally dysregulated i think it's
called the hpa axis the hypothalamus
pituitary adrenal access and it helps us
to physically look at a threat and
assess like a proportionate and
appropriate response this is
dysregulated in these people completely
disregulated that is an overreaction
me being unvaccinated and walking around
is not
causing people to just fall down dead in
my wake
that's not how this works
also when we use vaccines we typically
go through trial periods phase three
phase four to see if they work because
we have developed vaccines we developed
one for swine flu back in 2013 and we
withdrew it
i'm not a monster for choosing to wait
and see whether this will eventually be
withdrawn well you know your point about
emotional dysregulation and over threat
misassessment which is absolutely a
hundred percent what we're dealing with
here right
is
the i think there was a study that came
out that people who watch cnn and i'm
not picking on cnn specifically because
other media institutions do as well but
people who watch cnn that was the study
i saw
i think they
they said that if you catch covey your
chance of going to hospital was like 40
percent when it's like 0.1 percent that
i don't quote me in these numbers but
the ratios yeah the ratios or something
it wouldn't surprise me because the
statistics and the way things are being
reported
demonstrates statistical illiteracy as
we were talking about literacy sorry
yeah no no you're right but
the thing is that when it's at the
individual level i can understand
that it might be illiteracy
but when it starts to get to that level
of media coverage
i'm sorry
it starts to
feel
and it's just a feeling i'm not claiming
anything it's feeling you know the facts
don't care about my feelings but it
starts to feel like
there's there's more of a determined
agenda there do you know what it's like
propaganda yeah almost like propaganda
and
maybe in almost certainly in my opinion
it's well intentioned right the idea is
look we've got a disease we've got to
get people to take it seriously yeah but
the damage they've done in the process
you know it worries me a lot
because
you know people laugh it off and we joke
about it and we do the nazi accent and
all of that stuff but if you've got
countries in in europe
putting
separating people
based on whether they've taken a vaccine
to protect them from a virus that has a
0.1 mortality rate
that's a problem and then placing them
under house arrest perhaps when they
leave the house we can recognize them
with an armband yeah
it's insane man it's absolutely insane
so maybe maybe we should all despair
this is the black pill episode
but if we despair through this despair
what brave new world we could
create on that happy note
our hour is up man listen it's been an
absolute pleasure we're let's get you
back sometime and tell me more because
it's been really great to meet you thank
you but we've got one more question for
you which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be um we probably should be
talking about uh
the rather thorny subject of trauma and
the effect that it has on people's
perceptions of the world it's thorny
because nobody wants to talk about the
ways in which they were hurt
but a lot of the things that we're
seeing the threat misassessment
the tendency to split reality into good
and bad all of this is trauma based and
we need to have
an open conversation about the way in
which our perception of the world and
our sorting of the world and the schemas
we use to make sense of reality is
massively informed by the personal
trauma that we all as human beings have
experienced
i'm sure we'll talk about that next time
we've got a couple of questions for our
local supporters as well but in the
meantime where can people find you
follow you etc uh my website is
spartanlifecoach.com and if they put my
name into youtube they'll find my videos
richard on youtube thanks for being with
us and thank you for watching and
listening at home we'll see you very
soon with another brilliant episode like
this one or raw show all of them go out
at 7 pm uk time and if you want your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below